abone ol
[Müzik]
Ne
yapayım
uğraşıyorum
olduğu zaman
Çünkü o
[Müzik]
Sen
yapay zekalı mısın Çünkü biz Ortada
ulaştırıyoruz ki
şimdi o
[Müzik]
bu dünyanın en sevdiğin zaman
ediyorum
Çünkü
gerçekten mi
[Müzik]
ne yaptın gerçekleştiriyor yani
baktığımız zaman yavru yapar Zaten hepsi
söyledim ihtiyacımız var
[Müzik]
bu
çünkü matematik
Düşünüyorum
düşünüyorum Ne zaman bugün mü
[Müzik]
bu peki
bu soktu Pro
arkasındaki tarihsel gerçek gerçekliği
fazla gerçek Tamam
yani şu an o
En azından bu alana girerken
Neden Çünkü
[Müzik]
bunu kendi Ha o
Evet
şimdi belli başlı sorular da
cevap veremiyorum örnek veriyorum
hayatınız olamak istemiyorlar o
[Müzik]
Bu
evin karşısı problem çıkıyor
[Müzik]
Çünkü
alıyorum şimdi ben başka bir de
[Müzik]
bu uzunluğu durumda bir sonraki durumu
hareket ediyor
artık ya o
[Müzik]
o
insanlarla Duymasın'da
düşündüğümüzde göre de işte
Ama şunu söyleyeyim
çok tuhaf
bütün insanlar aslında o
[Müzik]
bu Eğer şu an çok kısa göstereceğim
benim dediğim Aslında ayak
çok daha
benim hayal ettim de
yok
ya biraz
size bakın
çok fazla o
[Müzik]
bu zeka o
çocuk o
[Müzik]
O
çok düşünürsünüz getirebiliriz ama
düşüreceğiz var orada bıraktım Sizin
evinize geldiğinizde ve geçersin
O yüzden biraz
toplanmış hali Aslında o
[Müzik]
ben size
yapacağım
Yani bu problemle hiç
fark etmez insanın formülü edebileceği
bir problem dedi
oluştuğu zaman buna uygun mu
Bu
soruya cevap verdiğin zaman
bazı sorulara cevaplar önce
çıkmamız gerekiyor o
[Müzik]
ama ben sürekli
olmak istemiyorum
şunu yapamam sıfırdan başkasında bu
şekilde o
bu sizden şu an
bu da zamanı
[Müzik]
Aslında görevlerini
Sizden ricam o
[Müzik]
çok
[Alkış]
merak ettim ya